hi there I think thank you for staying
this late I'm between you and the
cocktails so I'll try to be quick but
interesting at the same time i'm here to
talk today about the node foundation how
many of you guys are users of known so
about half that's pretty good alright
and some of this you're going to know
about it there's also a little history
lesson in here because i like to remind
people of where we came from and you
know i've been talking about open source
for almost 20 years now and i love it
that we that we won to the extent that
we have one but i noticed that if we
don't stay vigilant and keep reminding
people especially new people what's
happening we run the risk of losing it
again because it's a slippery slope it's
really easy to give up you know little
concessions along the way that the you
know add up to the end of open source so
we'll talk about that a little bit too
all right so jun 2014 I was at foo camp
which is a conference that Tim O'Reilly
gives it's an invitational conference in
his backyard and he literally pitch
tents and you know I was kind of minding
my own business in there and this guy
walks up to me this is michael rogers
and he has been caring about JavaScript
and and also know Jas for quite a long
time now and he wanted to understand
about copyright because there had just
been a change in the node community the
trademark holder of node had
unilaterally decided to stop aggregating
copyright that means you didn't have to
sign the little piece of paper anymore
to give a contribution and he wanted to
understand what the effect of that was
going to be and exactly what was going
to happen
next and as it happened I did know a
little bit about node and the reason
that I knew about note at all was
because I had gone to work a few months
earlier for paypal so paypal switched to
node in 2013 and they did this in a very
calculated way some of you may have seen
this gentleman talking about the switch
because he was kind of the architect of
it this is bill Scott he came from
netflix to paypal with the goal of
changing the way that paypal front ended
and he wanted to use this tool this tool
node and at the time at 2013 paypal was
still front ending in java and he's from
texas he's a really sweet guy and when
the people at PayPal that were nervous
about change asked him you know what he
was doing he said I'm just prototype in
you don't have to worry I'm just proud
to type in and he knew that eventually
this was going to end up being
production code but he also knew that
they weren't ready to hear it yet he
waited until the Java developers were
begging to be allowed to use node
because two people very small team were
able to get more done than like our team
of 25 people trying to front end in Java
and they were losing the race so they
wanted to switch to the other side so
anyway this is why I knew about it he
called me up and said I would like you
to talk to us about how to make our
contribution to the open source world
around node really successful and that
was the first you're going to do this
for me what are you doing oh that's
terrible Apple all right
so in 2014 we will they released Kraken
the beginning of the year I had helped
them with all the details of it to make
it have the best possible landing and I
did this as a consultant and lo and
behold it was really successful and they
listen to me carefully and they did
everything I told them to do so then
they said you should be an employee and
I said well why would I do that I'm a
consultant I like my life and they they
basically made it so I couldn't say no
one of the things they did was they let
me keep my consultancy open so I have a
lot of interesting conversations with
people but back then when they released
Kraken which is a framework that sits on
top of express and mix node run at
PayPal scale which is lots and lots of
transactions especially at Christmas
time and it's kind of a bumper area so
that our developers have a lot of choice
they can pick whatever modules they
think they want to use but they can't
get in too much trouble because this
framework is keeping making sure that
they can run at scale this is a these
are the companies that were using node
in everyday work in 2014 when we
released crackin and this is from an
article that Joyent who's the trademark
holder was what you know put out and it
was impressive list I was really
surprised Wow all right we'll just keep
doing this periodically until it goes
away but also they had a passionate
ecosystem I noticed I noticed that
because somebody started a campaign of
people from the ecosystem introducing
themselves to me as I was joining paypal
because they were hoping that we would
do more for node that we would be more
interested in no time we we you know
keep lifting it Michael had already
explained to me that there was a problem
and so you know I knew that something
was coming so I started a conversation
with this guy this is a his knee
um Stewart Hammond sorry it's because
the network is out so it won't let me
actually quit out of that piece of
software do what ignore thank you I did
try that once before just so you know so
um this is the guy Scott Hammond who is
the CEO of giant who owned the trademark
for node and who had made the he's not
the one who made the decision but I
started talking to him because he's the
one who would have to make a decision if
something was going to change for node
and I spent a lot of time talking to him
and I want to say he's and he's a smart
man he's very interested in getting it
right he's passionate about doing the
right things for the technology but also
getting some credit for what he thinks
was reasonable stewardship even though
he wasn't there he's a brand new CEO but
he likes the idea that his company looks
you know does well in addition to know
doing well and I wanted to help him out
I really did so over time we we we got
there but I gotta say that it's really
hard to learn open source if you're from
a proprietary point of view he's had
various things that he didn't understand
over the time that that we've been
talking and he gets through them and
then and then another one comes up and
it's really interesting because it remit
mirrors my consulting world when I had
to explain it to clients so for instance
one day he was very upset because one of
the major vendors in the node space was
wrapping the open source code was the
proprietary code and in putting it out
as a product and he didn't think that
that should be possible because it was
open source and I said permissive
licensing dude that's the name of the
game that's what you want you want that
adoption he's like really why do I want
this you know endless problems like that
and the main one was and it took me a
long time to realize his focus is on end
users not on the developers that are
create
the software because in his business
life he has to focus on the end user and
he thinks of the developers his
employees as cogs in a wheel like a lot
of employers but of course open source
turns out on its head those those core
developers are the whole deal they're
everything and the users it's nice if
the users can use the software but it's
really about those core developers so
this was a little different for him but
we we slide through it now we're going
to have time out first story so remember
that I talked that i was talking to
Scott Hammond we're going to talk about
a completely different thing that
happened 12 years earlier okay so once
upon a time there was this technology
called Java you guys all know Java how
many of you have coded in java yeah okay
good so Java was not open source java
had not been open source ever and it was
problematic until this guy made a
statement at a conference in Tokyo he
said the Java would be open source the
next year and then he quit I don't want
to comment on mr. Barrett's and why he
would do that but shortly after that I
got tapped on the shoulder and a sushi
bar in cupertino across from Apple's
headquarters and asked if I wanted to
open source java and i called my husband
up like i do and i said do i want to
open source java he said yes you do yes
you want to do that and i said why do I
want to do that he said cuz you're
really stubborn and you probably get it
right eventually alright so when mr.
Barrett's left there was a power vacuum
this is a dyson vacuum but that the what
I'm talking about is there was no
leadership in the company and the people
who invested in Java were really upset
so I you may know that for the ten first
years of Java the biggest companies in
the valley all gave
million dollars apiece every year so
that Java would be developed son figured
out that they could create partnerships
with all these companies because
everybody wanted this thing the idea of
write once run anywhere was really
compelling so everybody wanted a piece
of that so they could they showed up
though they are the people who'd been
paying money in and they said son you
don't have your act together you need to
give us this technology we've been
paying for all this time I mean give it
to us we shouldn't be running this
anymore you're bad stewards right and
this was some of the biggest companies
you could their household names you know
most of them and you know what to do
what to do right well this guy and this
is the best picture I could find of him
this is John canna guard and he is the
unsung hero of open source java he's the
one who was running java soft the
division he said you know what it's true
that we have a power vacuum and it's
true that they've been putting money in
but they're the wrong people to run java
going forward java should be run by
everybody who has a stake in the game
and so really what was happening was he
kind of put on his his colored glasses
his rose-colored glasses and he came up
with this idea of this sort of commune
that they were going to start around
java and it was going to be called the
java community process now he's the one
who had pushed Tomcat so tom cat came
from a very senior person who you know
saw the opportunity and put money
together to build a team to create
Tomcat which was the servlet api put
into open source out of java and they
did it because microsoft was get
otherwise on the web and they needed to
drive adoption and this was the fastest
way to drive adoption for an alternative
so that's why we have tomcat so he was
kind of a visionary about open source
from the beginning and then we started
the java community process he asked me
to get Apache involved
and I did that I've been an Apache
member for a long time I told them you
know this is it this is an opportunity
because you guys care about Java I don't
know how much of a hassle it's going to
be I'll just warn you you're going to be
the only ones that are really pushing
for open source but you know canna guard
wants this to happen and they said okay
we'll do it so so then and here we are
again all right you think that if I do
what I can't do that and I can't do that
either apparently Apple I don't know
what to do with this now I think we're
gonna have to escape out of it and try
do this all right I think that's really
still not going to work but we'll try it
all right so they were they were happy
together tom cat was doing really well
and then it came time to renegotiate the
document that bound all of the members
of the java community together and this
includes IBM and oracle and motorola and
apple and God and everybody Microsoft
even everybody's in there right they
wanted to renegotiate it because there
were some bugs in the process they found
and so they're doing this and the guy
from Apache and the guy from Apache is
caught is sitting through these long
calls every week two hours of his time
three hours of his time and he's a
volunteer but he's in there he's working
hard to get that done and one time he
asks the lawyer on a call would it be
possible to do tom cat under this new
agreement because that was what was
happening at Apache all they cared about
was you know are we going to be in
violation of this future agreement and
the answer was tom cat wouldn't be
possible even son could not do open
source java under the agreement that
they were writing and you know apache
they got mad
they got really mad like 200 200 very
influential engineers the members of
Apache were saying well we can't stay in
this organization because it's not going
to be open source anymore and that's
what we're here for so they announced
that they were going to leave and now
that could not happen so they negotiated
a compromise and these guys are the ones
who did it the one on this side is Rob
jingle he was the CTO of Java soft and
the one on this side is Jason hunter and
he actually lives in singapore now so I
had dinner with him a couple nights ago
but he's the one who was on the phone
for these long long calls and they
negotiated something that they called
the Apache compromise it basically said
that Apache should be allowed because
they're good guys and they care about
compatibility and they have the right
goals for java they're not trying to
break it they should be allowed to
reimplement the java specs in open
source as long as they do it compatibly
this was a huge piece of news in 2003
because I had been working since 1999 to
try to open source java and mostly i got
this from the people that wrote java so
this was a really big change so then I
convinced Rob that it needed to be
something that was publicly known
because transparency open source and
Java one was what was going to happen
like the next week so could we just walk
on stage and have a conversation maybe
between keynotes because rob was going
to be the emcee of java one that year
and so there was no way to get a real
announcement out because PR it takes
months to do those announcements but
also they didn't like the idea of this
they were part of this you know they
didn't want to see java open sourced and
so but they didn't want to fire me
either they just could have left me
around so now you have to think about
this six in the morning we're walking
across Howard Street to go in
do the rehearsal for the keynote this is
Jason and me now it's really early in
the morning for Jason he's a programmer
how many of you like to get up at six in
the morning yeah like almost nobody
right so he's grumpy and we're walking
across the street across the zebra
crossing and we run and see I told you
it was going to do it sorry well I made
it go away though okay and so we run
into this lady she was in charge of
brand her name was Tracy stout and she
and I are walking across the crosswalk
and she says what are you doing here
Denise and I said oh I have my friend
Jason hunter he's going to be on stage
really briefly between two of the
keynotes he's from Apache he's going to
talk about open source java and she says
that's nice and then we get down down
the stairs she goes into the green room
where scott mcnealy who has a keynote
that day is not happy with his speech
and you see how in this picture scott is
holding select a little stack of cards
that's how he did his keynotes they were
written out very very specifically and
then he'd rip went off and throw it over
his shoulder sometimes in the middle of
the keynote you know right so he's
backstage he doesn't like his talk and
he is throwing cards and he's yelling
and everybody's terrified and Tracy
comes in and she says he basically he's
upset because he doesn't think there's
anything newsworthy in his keynote he
says I'm the CEO there should be
something interesting in this talk why
can't I get something interesting to say
and Tracy says I just ran into Denise in
the crosswalk and she's got this guy
from Apache and open source java and he
says bring me that kid ok so we're in
the front of the house jason has his
microphone on we're standing there and
he's all gaga because because james
gosling is standing there and he's
talking to him there's nobody there in
the in the audience at all it's six in
the more
right and so Scott Scott gets a hold of
jason and the next thing I know Jason is
the featured event at Scott's keynote
and they stand on stage and they talk
about open source java in front of not
only the 28,000 people that are
physically in the room because they're
literally are that many people that fit
in moscone but also the millions of
people that are watching this stream
this is the moment that it really
happened that we knew there would be
open Java but it took all of those
coincidences and all of that sort of
clandestine belief to make it happen so
is happy news for everybody that was
there by the way I really really hard
time finding a good picture of the
inside of moscone I will say it was not
happy news for everyone so you see how
you're sitting in the front row here
that's what happens when you are
babysitting a keynote at javaone they
make you sit in the front row and behind
you are all the people that work at Sun
and I mean every VP every director and
they're all angry because we got this
news out the door without any approval
any PR any anything and of course as
soon as the keynotes over every reporter
wants to know they're all really
interested in this big change so what
was the story what was this story about
this is how much work it was it used to
be to open source stuff it was really
hard and it took it took like acts of
God to get these companies to give up
their IP these days everybody gets it I
mean node is worth not quite as much as
Java but it's getting it the momentum of
how fast note is becoming the way you do
a front end and even the way you do sort
of the middleware and parts of the back
end it's amazing how fast it's happening
and and a lot of that is being driven by
the fact that it's open source you know
son spent an incredible amounts of money
getting every single kid in the cs
departments of the world
to learn java and and i don't know that
they're teaching note i think they're
still teaching java because they're sort
of stuck in the old way of doing things
but note is available for everybody to
use and learn and it really is becoming
the the tool of choice so i just say the
rest is history meanwhile now we're
going to come back through the present
back at node we set up an advisory board
as soon as God Hammond was comfortable
enough to do that and it was all the
stakeholders that were agitating for
change including some really really big
companies and we met publicly we met
every month we you know slowly but
surely we're starting to talk about what
should happen not everybody loves
process however and a lot of the key
engineers that were working on note in
the technical committee got really bored
and they ended up famously creating a
community fork I ojs and this turned out
to be a really valuable thing that they
did so when they spend a lot of energy
and how they wanted to work together in
the future how things needed to change
for them to feel comfortable and they
documented that stuff really well
Michael Rogers who you saw the picture
of earlier was kind of in the middle of
making sure that documentation was clean
and reasonable and there were good you
know well thought out plans for how
things were going to change and move
forward totally valuable work and
honestly no foundation wouldn't exist
without that work today so we got them
started talking to the linux foundation
that turned out to be the best partner
for scott for giant because they really
talked in business terms a lot of their
thrust is about is about earning money
for the technology so that it can go
forward and so that's why we went with
them we had a panel at node summit where
we first talked about the likelihood
that this was going to happen really for
real in june and the guy on the on this
side here that's Jim's Emlyn who runs
the linux foundation so that was a group
of interested parties including yes God
Hammond is in the middle there talking
about the desire to create a foundation
and the hope that I ojs would come back
into the fold now there haven't been
that many Forks that have healed in the
history of open-source just a handful
maybe like less than five total and the
biggest one was pearl and that was
almost 25 30 years ago now so I was
really excited to be involved on in
fixing this one and eventually we got
chartered yes in August and that was a
really really big deal I ojs said that
they would come back if we if we did it
properly this is where we are now with
sponsoring members it's a lot of big
companies and a lot of small companies
that are involved in the node community
and this is a pay-to-play board that
means all these people are paying money
to have a seat somewhere on the table
that to me is a bug in open source I
honestly think that pay to play is the
wrong way to go because think about it
open source is people I am involved in
node but because I have a seat that was
paid for by my company if I were to
leave paypal i would also be walking
away from that seed and that's not how
open source works open source is about
people becoming passionate about
technology and sticking it out
regardless of where they sit you know
when i left son i was sitting on the OSI
board the Open Source Initiative board
and we had just changed presidents went
from the guy who had done it for a long
time you guys probably know eric raymond
to michael teman who worked for red hat
and i got a memo from jonathan schwartz
that said I'm uncomfortable with red hat
holding this seat why didn't you take it
now I had given notice his son I was
just working out my you know
the weeks until I changed and went off
to work for Intel and so I wrote back to
him I said well first of all Jonathan
you don't really have a seat on the
board I have a seat on the board I
happen to work for you but I actually
gave notice you know three weeks ago and
don't they tell you anything and and I'm
not going to be here much longer and
then some won't have any representatives
on OSI board because I'm going to go
work for Intel so then Intel will have
one you know so trying to explain to him
how that goes they're used to pay to
play they're used to a different kind of
arrangement and they're not they think
of resources and when I say they I mean
corporations think of resources as
fungible so remember i talked about how
Scott was thinking about the users but
not the engineers even a even a company
like son that's totally organized around
engineering still thinks of the
engineers as kind of cogs in a big
machine you know and we can tell you
where to work and we can tell you where
to work after that we can put you on an
open source project and get you all spun
up and then decide that it's not a good
investment and pull you off of it and
you should leave gracefully that's not
open source open source is like hell I'm
gonna leave I've got stuff to do here
I'm interested in this project you know
that's that's open source and and I'm
taking my seat with me when I leave
because I'm the one doing the work not
you so I think it's important that we
remember that if you work for a company
that allows you to work on an open
source and they expect to be able to
tell you when to stop you might want to
find another company do really good work
on that project you it shouldn't be too
hard okay come on Oh again again all
right there we go so node has a
technical steering committee the board
does not tell them what to do the
technical decisions are handled by the
steering committee this is in the bylaws
this is a condition of I ojs coming back
and it's the way open source
should be run because they're in it
because they care not because they paid
so this is one modification that we're
making to try to get to better open
source behavior their mission is really
good mission they exist as a board as a
foundation to promote through open
development in transparency the
furthering of nodejs that is our that is
our mission it's pretty straightforward
we have some working agreements like the
one I mentioned before where the
technical steering committee does not
get interference from from the board the
board works on fiduciary things like is
the trademark being serviced is there
enough money can we do is or do we need
something in the community like this sum
is there some missing thing that
nobody's picking up should we fund that
those kinds of things but we do not tell
them what to do the community is rich
they're really really enthusiastic there
they're very diverse extremely diverse
one of the big things is it's not
although it's a North American
Foundation it's not a North American
project it's a global project which is
what I'm doing here and why I will be
doing a lot of node conferences in the
next year around the world because it's
really important to get the message out
we really are trying to not make it a
North American thing we're hoping to
create an effective umbrella in the same
way that Apache is an umbrella for
projects we're working now on specifying
exactly what our umbrella attracts like
we don't want every project in the world
but we do have some key projects that we
think need a better home that we depend
on and the first one that we're probably
going to look at is Libby V because we
need it for note for I ojs node and it's
down to to maintain errs they're looking
for a home so that's probably the first
one I really really like their logo too
isn't it great but we don't know for
sure the
this is I'm letting you in on a future
possibility but it's not actually a done
deal yet we are funding a user
conference next month and the idea of
this conference is to create an
environment where you could bring people
who are making a decision about whether
to use node so right now if you go to a
node conf what you're going to meet is
the crazy community the wacky community
and and they're very committed and and
lovely and they don't necessarily sell
well to future customers you know hi I'm
from Colonel Sanders okay I'm from
Kentucky Fried Chicken I need to know
about this node thing why does that
person have a dress on isn't that a boy
you know doesn't work so we're trying to
make it clear that there's a technical
community and they need to meet and they
need to meet around the world but
there's also the potential user
community if this ecosystem is going to
grow there needs to be good places for
people to come in in a businesslike way
feel comfortable about the promise of
node so that's what this conference is
so we're calling for people that are
interested in node that want to see the
future of node and maybe want to see
their career grow in the node way to
consider getting involved with the
foundation what another change that
we've made to the sort of standard Linux
Foundation foundation thing is we have
added to community elected seats that
will be from the community at large so
you don't have to pay to get one of
these seats you do have to be elected by
the members by your peers and anyone can
become a member of the node foundation
if you are committed you can do that for
free if you are not a committer but you
just really interested you can do it for
not very much actual money but its low
price because you're an individual
because the goal is to just get people
involved and hooked into node and so
those two seats will be will be voting
seats and they'll come to every board
meeting and have
equals say to the rest of us in you know
board like decisions right and I just
had to put in a plug for Drupal 8
because you guys know Drupal 8 we've
been waiting for five years for Drupal 8
and it came out yesterday andriy spades
hearts birthday and I also serve on this
board so yay Drupal 8 how many of you
know Drupal yay go learn drupal 8 Drupal
8 is going to be really exciting and yes
I do in fact do these both of these
foundations and I'm on about four
different boards and this is another
thing you can do for open sources get
involved with this side of the business
because we always need good board
members in every one of these
foundations to try to help make good
decisions that are going to create you
know the open-source effect for as many
people as possible behind that
technology so if you're interested in
board service it's actually pretty great
and now let's see i have a glorious 11
minutes and 14 seconds for questions and
i will answer any question that you ask
probably truthfully hi hi so my question
is more of like how does a company get
involved with knoji as if they use it
daily they want to be a part of this and
like we're the guys who have to sell to
our boss like we should be a part of
this not just use it every day we should
also be part of the foundation how do we
a company or help you become a part of
the perfect i'm happy to tell you so
there's been a lot of research into how
open source participation works and
basically it's a pyramid so an Apache
where we have good statistics we know
that for every hundred users there are
10 people who are willing to contribute
so about one in ten actually come up
with a contribution and then for every
ten contributors there's like one or
maybe two trusted committers that come
out of that a trusted committer ship
means you've taken the time to learn the
codebase that you're contributing to and
you can explain it to somebody else and
you can conduct code
and help mentor other people so when you
join as a user and you see something
that you want to fix your job is to
figure out how to submit that patch
listen to the mentor listen to the
trusted committer make whatever changes
need to be made until it's acceptable to
that trusted committer believe that they
have the project's best interest at
heart they're not just being mean to you
there you know like there's a real
conversation you can have and then learn
enough about that process to gradually
submit enough patches that you can do it
and you know how to do it and then you
can explain it to somebody else we talk
a lot about that ramp and then lowering
the barrier to entry getting people
involved in any open source project but
especially node coming up with a list of
things that a beginner could do includes
you're having to read the documentation
if it doesn't make sense to you and you
figure out what the answer is you could
write it more clearly so the next person
wouldn't stumble the same way you do if
somebody asks a question that you asked
two months ago and you got an answer you
could answer this time because you know
the answer now because you heard it two
months ago it's that layering on of
generosity and an honest human
connection that makes open source so
compelling for developers because you
really can get your questions answered
you really can learn the new thing you
really can gain reputation and once you
have that public reputation you can
leverage that open source developers get
paid thirty percent more globally that's
been confirmed in three different
studies now why because we're better
developers because we're willing to let
our code be seen in public that that
just automatically makes us better in
fact any developer in the whole world if
they knew their code was going to be
seen in public I promise you they'd be
more careful maybe better developers
it's just what happens so does that help
good Thank You Denise thank you so much
sure
all the way like short term to actually
Thank You the knees